let's look at infidelity a little bit
deeper because this is one of the I
think when I talk about societal decay
um this is one of the things that really
gets me the most is how many people are
cheating and what I found here when I
looked at these numbers this is from
hack Spirit from 2022 how much cheating
is going on what I found is a lot of
cheating was going on that was not a
surprise to me but that men and women
are cheating for very very different
reasons again a lot of people surmise
that women are cheating because they're
bored or because of the fine of this
financial distress I think you'll be
surprised to see exactly why it is I was
not actually surprised by that number
let's take a look though this talks
about the disparity in numbers of how
much infidelity is going on some
websites have published unverified
numbers claiming about 40 percent of
unmarried relationships and 25 percent
of marriages see at least one incident
of infidelity another estimate this is
from the Journal of marriage and divorce
concludes that 70 of married Americans
cheat at least once in their marriage
that number sounds a little high to me
but again you see the disparity in stats
more reliable numbers from the U.S
general Social Survey point to lower
statistics but they're still worse
worrisome right even if it's a 39
percent
it still worrisome it's why why is it
happening
okay so let's take a look
a poll from Super drug online doctor
found that men and women cheat for very
different reasons
so they do a chart the top five reasons
people have been tempted to cheat or
have cheated I'm going to focus on
American women and American men on the
right the left is European I think that
culturally there are a lot of
differences that come into play there
it's just too hard to cover that all
today so let's focus on on the United
States American women number one reason
my partner stopped paying attention to
me
okay number two the other person was
really there for me again that's like
one of the same your partner wasn't
paying attention somebody else was I was
having doubts about my relationship the
other person was really hot it's number
four
it's not even about that tell you that
and number five is I was bored that
reason that people cite the most often
boredom is actually number five on there
for women
look at American men number one
hotness okay men are very visual two
people were hitting on me
three was having doubts about my
relationship for my partner and I
weren't having sex everybody thinks it's
like that's another accusation that gets
thrown oh well they weren't having
enough sex in the homes the guy went out
and no oftentimes that's not the case
and fine my partner stopped paying
attention to me very very different
again that partner not stopped paying
attention to me is number one
for a reason women cheat and number five
for men I don't know if you remember on
the podcast a few weeks ago I had said
something to the effect of I don't know
who I was talking to maybe I was talking
to Adam and I said If a woman marries a
guy for the wrong reasons let's say it's
strictly Financial this guy's got a lot
of money end of story
you will oftentimes within a very short
period of Time find that that woman is
divorced or sleeping with the bartender
I said down the street who plays music
for her doesn't have a lot of money but
makes her feel wanted needed appreciated
boom
there you see it 100 women need to feel
that you are present engaged and
appreciated oftentimes that shows up in
ridiculous media conversations about
like oh don't forget to buy flowers for
Valentine's Day and that's not what
we're saying
I don't care about flowers on
Valentine's Day oftentimes it's you went
and did something for no reason at all
right it's a day that's not Valentine's
Day it's not her birthday it's not
Christmas and you went out and you were
like babe you know what I know you like
roses I stopped by a store and I thought
I'd pick you pick these up for you or
whatever it may be it doesn't have to be
flowers it could be chocolates it could
be a candy bar it could be it can be
simple it doesn't have to be all
diamonds and oh diamond ring and it's
not all about money
it's about caring enough to make
somebody feel appreciated that's number
one based on what these people have said
I would concur
what's interesting in this too is how
did people meet the person with whom
they cheated or attempted to cheat with
number one
for women and men they were a friend
so that's an interesting conversation to
have at another time and maybe we'll do
that in our shoot the [ __ ] on Wednesday
we have Vinnie oshana here on Wednesday
by the way for a shoot it's going to be
fun maybe we talk about can you have
can you be friends with someone from of
the opposite sex I'm based in this
conversation on heterosexual relations
because it gets just too complicated to
bring everything into play right
so they were friends number two reason
for where the cheating happened at work
what I found shocking is that in this
day and age social media is all the way
down
dating app or website is is further down
so it's still coming from Friends people
you trust
people who are you may confide in about
your relationship that's bad by the way
we'll talk about why one day but you
shouldn't be like
you're a female you got a guy friend you
don't call that guy friend and talk
about your marriage and what's going on
that's wrong that's weird it's
inappropriate don't do that it's
disrespectful you have a problem with
your relationship you talk to your man
about it
that's how that should roll but you know
they talked to that guy and they're just
friends and that guy starts to console
you and suddenly
there you go if you like the short clip
you can catch another one here or you
can catch the full episode right here
[Music]